[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's something all of
us need to begin to internalize
just because something seems far-fetched
or it seems crazy or it seems totally
destructive to core american interests
doesn't mean the us government won't do
it that's the main lesson of the moment
we're living in so with that in mind do
not discount no matter how far-fetched
it may seem a hot war with russia
yes that is a lunatic idea there is
nothing we could possibly gain from a
military confrontation with vladimir
putin and there's very much we could
lose including of course many thousands
of american lives
but that doesn't mean joe biden won't do
it biden is unpopular he's uncompetent
and he's desperate but more than
anything joe biden is weak he is a pawn
of his staff and the hard-eyed
ideologues who surround him
russia is currently involved in a border
dispute with neighboring ukraine many of
biden's closest aides are pushing the
united states to get involved militarily
now among the many many ironies here is
that the ukraine crisis was largely
created by joe biden's own aides and
many people like them throughout all
levels of the us government
so here's the russian position for
russia the core question is nato nato is
the post-war military alliance created
in 1949 to keep the soviets from
invading western europe and it worked
pretty well for about 40 years but the
soviet union has not existed in more
than three decades it's part of history
now and yet nato very much lives on
better funded than ever it is an army
without a purpose
so at this point nato exists primarily
to torment vladimir putin who whatever
his many faults has no intention of
invading western europe vladimir putin
does not want belgium he just wants to
keep his western border secure that's
why he doesn't want ukraine to join nato
and that makes sense imagine how we
would feel if mexico and canada became
satellites of china we wouldn't like
that at all
in russia's case this is an existential
question a nato takeover of ukraine
would compromise russia's access to its
sebastopol naval base that's the site of
the russian black sea fleet and one of
the country's only connections to
international waters
in the words of russia's scholar richard
saqqa if russia lost the sevastopol
naval base it would be quote the biggest
military geopolitical defeat of russia
in the last thousand years
so for vladimir putin that's
unacceptable it's a disaster he cannot
let it happen he will not let it happen
but for the united states and this is
the main point here there would be no
benefit either the united states would
gain precisely nothing from taking over
ukraine why would we want to do that
at best we'd be driving russia and we
are in fact deeper into the arms of the
government of china and that would be a
disaster for the united states and a
disaster for the world
so why are we doing this why is the u.s
government pushing ukraine to join nato
well god knows why but we are doing this
both parties are doing this the neocons
around joe biden are for it of course as
they are for every sinister and stupid
idea but so is former secretary of state
mike pompeo a smart man so is ohio
senator rob portman
so many republicans
so this is a bipartisan sort of insanity
the question is can joe biden stand up
to it and the answer is come on biden
has always been more lobbyist than
leader he says what he's told to say
once it was the credit card companies in
delaware that wrote his scripts now it's
the neocons of the state department it's
the same idea
biden spoke today with vladimir putin by
video call and according to the white
house he informed the russian leader
that the united states plans to control
ukraine no matter what
secretary of state and struggling pop
musician tony blinken repeated that
message he threatened to send american
troops there here's tony blinken
spokesman
if russia chooses to fail to de-escalate
if russia chooses to move forward
with any plans
it may have developed
to
continue its military aggression or to
aggress militarily
upon ukraine to violate ukraine's
sovereignty its independence its
territorial integrity
we and our allies would be prepared to
act we would be prepared to act
resolutely
these such children ukraine's
territorial integrity that's the concern
that's what this is really about they're
telling us because if there's one thing
the biden white house cares about
it's secure borders at least in eastern
europe where borders are not racist
ukraine's borders must be defended it
would be immoral to open those borders
to the world and allow say tens of
thousands of unemployed haitians to pour
across we can't allow that in fact we
will send american troops to ukraine to
prevent that
open borders are only permitted in texas
arizona and california and anywhere else
the potential democratic voters might
arrive uninvited from the third world
but ukraine no ukraine is a god-given
right to territorial integrity and
american soldiers will die to defend
that territorial integrity
that's our official position as a
country
now according to cnn we must stop these
russian attacks on the sacred borders of
ukraine because if we don't stop then
what we could have here is what cnn is
calling a dire security situation now
that phrase apparently comes from joe
biden's under secretary of state tori
newland who according to cnn gave a
quote gloomy briefing to u.s senators
last night
now tori newland is strongly in favor of
war with russia what's amazing is that
anyone
anywhere is still listening to her
no serious person could take victoria
nuland seriously she's a joke not only
is she obviously unimpressive as a
person ask anyone who knows her and
she's not especially pro-american by the
way she was one of the architects of the
disaster in iraq
so why is tori and newland still talking
about foreign policy is the guy who
designed chernobyl still building
nuclear reactors
probably not
only in washington where failure is
assiduously rewarded could someone like
victoria nuland still wield power which
she absolutely does
it's scary when you think about it
toriya newand is driving our ukraine
policy which of course is being
justified by our broader support for
quote democracy now keep that in mind as
you listen to this this is the same the
same tory newland who was caught on tape
several years ago scheming about how to
end democracy in ukraine here's nuland
in a leaked audio recording plotting the
overthrow of ukraine's democratically
elected president
listen as nuland rattles off a list of
potential puppets to install in place of
the democratically elected president is
the guy who's got the economic
experience the governing experience he's
he's the gut you know what he needs is
clich and tony book on the outside he
needs to be talking to them four times a
week
you know
i i just think klitsch going in he's
going to be at that level working for
yatsenyuk it's just not going to work
yeah no i think that's i think that's
right okay
it's just not going to work what about
the voters of ukraine who thought they
were engaged in democracy nope there's
torrey newland working to overthrow
democracy keep in mind if they'll do it
there they will do it here
you're hearing the same state department
goon who worked to organize a coup in
ukraine telling us we need to go to war
with russia to preserve democracy in
ukraine these people have no shame
so the question is what is this really
about of course it's not about democracy
for which they have zero respect well in
part it's a hangover from the lunatic
russia hoax that absorbed washington for
three years everything about vladimir
putin is bad therefore let's have a war
with him
a lot of people think that but there's
also a deeper cause here that's rarely
noted for years ukrainian interests have
pumped millions of lobbying dollars into
washington dc to change american foreign
policy in the region at one point as you
may have heard they employed the
president's own son to repeat their
talking points so tens of thousands of
dollars a month to tell us that russia
is bad and we need to stand with ukraine
because democracy even as we work to
overthrow democracy in ukraine
so with that in mind now that you know
that maybe you were not so surprised
when joe biden concluded that vladimir
putin doesn't possess a soul
you said you know he doesn't have a soul
i did say that to him yes and to end his
response was we understand one another i
wasn't being a wise guy i was alone with
him in his office that's how it came
about it was when
president bush had said i've looked in
his eyes and saw a soul
i said looked in your eyes and i don't
think you have a soul and looked back
and he said we understand each other so
you know vladimir putin you think he's a
killer
i do
these people are children again children
pretending to be leaders veteran putin's
a killer
presumably unlike every other head of
state on earth through all human history
but honestly that is not the relevant
question vladimir putin's soul
who cares
we can leave that to his priest assuming
he has one the only question that
matters the only question is how does
intervening in ukraine help the core
interests of the united states and of
course that is the one question no one
in washington is asking
watch the pentagon's obedient little
flak a man with so little dignity he'll
say whatever he's told to say brag about
how much military equipment we are now
sending to ukraine and notice as you
watch this tape that he never even
thinks about explaining why we would be
sending that military equipment
we have
uh provided
millions of dollars worth of lethal and
non-lethal assistance to ukraine in just
the last you know 10 months 11 months
nothing has changed about
our commitment to making sure that
ukraine
has what it needs to defend itself
so say what you will about donald trump
and his twitter account maybe you liked
him maybe you're appalled by his
personal style
but in retrospect if there is one thing
that donald trump deserves eternal
credit for is keeping idiots like that
in their box for four years there were
no pointless wars under donald trump
that is not a small thing in recent
american history in fact it's rarely
happened over the past century
but through unwavering determination for
which he has not gotten credit if
there's one thing in new zealand's
credit for it's this donald trump pulled
that off he resisted again and again
when members of congress and guys from
raytheon when all the interested parties
pushed him to go to war here there and
everywhere donald trump resisted that
and in washington above all they hated
him for that in the end they impeached
him for it
as one witness put it during our
impeachment inquiry
the united states age ukraine and her
people
so that we can fight russia over there
and we don't have to fight russia here
really we're gonna fight russia here are
we adam schiff adam schiff of course
a dumb person and a partisan democrat
but what's so interesting and ought to
make you sit up and pay attention is
suddenly partisan republicans are making
identical noises
just this afternoon senator roger wicker
of mississippi not a genius famously but
still a sitting republican center
went on fox news to say we may need to
send american troops to ukraine and
possibly because this isn't insane or
anything
think about the use of nuclear weapons
got that in our back pocket nuclear
weapons
roger wicker sitting u.s senator
no one in washington laughed at roger
wicker
this is so crazy that no one seems aware
of how crazy it is they're all just
sitting back and listening to tori and
newland
tell them
what we need to do
how much has this penetrated the psyche
of washington dc well here's a sad piece
of tape this is joni ernst who's totally
affable nice republican sort of
reasonable in most things from the
midwest suddenly sounding like a
bloodthirsty warmonger something like
actually adam schiff when she talks
about that dastardly vladimir putin
he needs to say to vladimir putin that
we are no longer going to allow you to
to continue with the nordstream 2
pipeline we need you to know and
understand that we will defend ukraine
and we will provide them assistance he
needs to make that very clear
putin is so bad we're going to cut off
natural gas to western europe
in retaliation against him in december
we're gonna freeze germany and
luxembourg and that's gonna teach
vladimir putin again what you just saw
there is a child who has no idea what
she's talking about but keeps talking
anyway we will defend ukraine says joni
ernst
remember this is a senator from iowa so
what happens if we don't defend ukraine
joni ernst will kids in des moines grow
up to speak russian
no one asked her that question she's
never thought about it for a moment that
all is reading from the same talking
points from adam schiff to roger wicker
to joni ernst
it turns out that foreign lobbying
campaigns work pretty well and that's
why the ukrainians paid for one in
washington hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else